un an quoi d'être arrivé comme ça ne pas
être sorti du ventre d'une mère ou mon
adoption
a été difficile à vivre pendant des
années à un moment je me suis demandé si
c'était pas plutôt l'abandon ou le déni
l'abandon au départ l'adoption c'est
toujours une histoire d'amour mais il
arrive parfois qu'elle se termine mal en
france chaque année des enfants adoptés
sont renvoyés dans leur pays d'origine
ou rendu aux services sociaux
ils sont abandonnés une deuxième fois
une adoption c'est définitif on ne
revient pas dessus
normalement
[Musique]
jusqu'au jour où ça devient complètement
insupportable et là qu'est ce qu'on fait
on se ce fléau news on fait quoi
pour que ça s'arrête pour que ce soit
supportable pour que la vie redevienne
vivable pour comprendre comment cette
grève délicate peut échouer il faut
d'abord remonter bien avant l'adoption
quand ces enfants n'étaient encore que
des enfants adoptables
[Musique]
quand je suis en voyage en ethiopie et
que et que je vois un enfant dans la rue
je me dis valence
j'aurais pu être encore là contre quand
je vois le petit enfant de 6 ans qui
fait la manche je me dis oui c'était moi
je considère que je suis un survivant
quand on a rien on chances de survie
sont moins non pas que voilà je serai
peut-être mort tout simplement
depuis sa naissance l'enfant adoptée à
traverser une longue série d'épreuves
l'abandon le deuil parfois et souvent la
misère des premiers pas dans la vie qui
laisse des traces des blessures
d'enfance
[Applaudissements]
à la base j'étais abandonné le jour de
ma naissance
j'ai perdu ma mère et pour un bébé enfin
il ne comprend son existence qu'en
voyant sa mère en face cette blessure le
s'effacer quand même la blessure
initiale donc c'est ce qui s'est passé
en avant même la rencontre avec mes
parents en quoi donc je pense c'est ce
qui m'a marqué et qui qui continue à me
poursuit quoi un peu après l'abandon
l'orphelinat la pouponnière un passage
presque obligé dans la vie d'un adopté
l'ethiopie est le deuxième pays
d'origine des enfants adoptés en france
il y a quinze ans julien et rpi dans
cette orpheline
quand je suis arrivé donc autocool à
l'orphelinat d'addis abeba en fait moi
on sortait pas quoi finalement
on sortait pas du tout cool la seule
chose que je me souvenais sais c'était
un portail bleu et puis j'étais qu'on
s'approchait du portail bleu des chiens
qui aboient quoi
à l'orphelinat du toukoul des enfants
arrivent de toute l'ethiopie orphelins
du sida ou abandonnés par des parents en
proie à la misère
à peine débarqués ils sont admis au
service des primo arrivants
quand elle est arrivée elle pesait 2 kg
le docteur nihat la pédiatre de
l'orphelinat leur donne les premiers
soit il leur fait passer une batterie de
tests médicaux
elle est le premier témoin des
traumatismes qu'ils ont subis avant leur
arrivée est arrivée elle était très mal
nutri elle était très amaigri
elle a encore des signes de malnutrition
regardez ces extrémistes et elle a
beaucoup perdu de poids sa mère est
morte quand elle lui a donné naissance
regardez elle répondent quand on la
stimule le problème c'est que les
enfants sont jetés dans la rue et quand
ils sont dans la rue ils sont exposés au
froid
et quand il fait très chaud il risque d
insolation qu'ils sont comme les rues
sont sales
ils peuvent être contaminés des
meilleurs ressorts ils peuvent aussi
être piqués par des insectes street on a
même eu des enfants avec des morsures de
chien qu'il souhaitait mousses de brest
messahel vient d'arriver
elle a été maintenue tri à cause de cela
elles ne marchent pas manquer
même si ce n'est pas une enfance
heureuse je peux pas vraiment dire que
je sois heureux parce que j'ai pas très
bien commencé ma vie en fait j'ai vécu
de la maltraitance
si mes souvenirs sont bons en fait
je me rappelle que mon premier pari
n'était pas toujours facile en fait
assure un coup bas
il me m'étranglait jusqu'à que je puisse
plus
respirer il m'enfermait dans
dans une pièce toute noire où je voyais
rien et il me laissait pendant plusieurs
jours dans cette histoire mais n'empêche
que que je sais très bien que calor fina
en tout cas j'étais bien
[Musique]
l'orpheline une bouée de sauvetage pour
ces enfants
ici les nounous les infirmières et la
pédiatre ce relais à leur chevet pour
les réconforter les aider à surmonter
leurs souffrances vous continuez
toujours à lui appliquer de la crème
vous la championne est toujours avec son
médicament
elle prend aussi du poids n'est ce pas
quand je vois les enfants pour la
première fois je suis comme une mère
comme n'importe quel être humain je me
sens triste s'il avait eu des parents il
serait resté avec eux pour les autres si
leurs parents va eu les moyens de les
garder il aurait grandi auprès d'eux et
certains sont vraiment dans une
situation critique
d'un autre côté je suis heureuse parce
que si ces enfants n'avaient pas pu être
accueillis ici il serait mort comment
des enfants qui ont vécu de tels
traumatismes peuvent-ils tourner la page
au moment de leur adoption
un passé ce lourd que certains préfèrent
le garder port 1
j'ai fait une chanson de rap qui
s'appelle my life en fait et qui raconte
en gros comment j'ai vécu les choses et
et et dans cette chanson je dis
clairement je dis j'ai vécu un passé
trouble et l'absence du verbe aimer on
n'a pas enseigné seul je me suis forgé
en quelque sorte et je le dis et
finalement c'est quelque chose que je
vais me suis approprié que j'ai pas et
que gégé s'est passé en quelque sorte un
peu de la paire de deux dans parler
ouvertement je pense que je vais en
parler ouvertement comme ça je le
ressens comme comme mon intimité comme
le secret de ma vie finalement julien
s'est construit sur un traumatisme comme
les deux mille enfants qui sont
recueillis au tout coule de quelques
semaines à leur majorité
certains grandiront ici d'autres comme
julien seront confiés à l'adoption
et
[Musique]
faire son lit laver les dents etc
c'était plus
en fait pour aussi les gens qui
n'allaient pas être forcément adopté à
prendre un certain ordre en fait les
petites phrases qui font leur lit c'est
en fait c'est un leurre à prendre même
dès cet âge à être vraiment carré quoi
m
quand je suis arrivé en france ça a
continué je veux dire ce que j'avais
appris la base quand je suis rentré dans
ma chambre ma chambre elle était
toujours rangée de façon impeccable quoi
[Musique]
on avait un repas on avait employé on
avait on n'avait pas les soucis mais
après sur le plan affectif c'est sûr que
il y avait pas eu les personnes âgées
rien n'avait peut-être pas les plus
chanceux c'était les bébés au moins il
avait les nous fait vrai
[Musique]
je restais de longs mois à l'orphelinat
en attendant d'être adopté un fait je le
souvenir d'une d'une grande solitude et
je le souvenir d'un de sentiments fêtes
où j'attendais qu'il se passe quelque
chose donc je sais pas si si j'attendais
d'être adoptée si j'attendais qu'on
revienne me chercher mais c'est sûr que
c'était pas très clair c'était assez
flou
60% de ses enfants ne quitteront jamais
l'orpheline certains n'ont pas été
officiellement abandonnée d'autres sont
trop âgés ou trop malades ils ne sont
pas adoptables ceux qui sont confiés à
l'adoption sont préparés par les nounous
à l'aide d'albums photos envoyées par
leurs parents adoptifs les enfants
s'imprègne de leur nouvelle vie à l'aigu
l'attend il y avait je pense beaucoup de
fantasmes autour de ces images là parce
que c'était c'était entre guillemets un
avenir
voilà deux et en ce qui me concerne je
pense que si on porte une issue de
secours un peu à ce moment là
chaleco d'austin machine à machine
makina aïeux et notamment chez les vip
sur toiture grâce qui gueule on leur
montre les albums jusqu'à leur départ
jusqu'à ce qu'il rencontre leur famille
voient leur père leur mère leur frère
leur chambre et on leur décrit tout et
quand ils iront là-bas ce ne sera pas
nouveau pour eux ils attendent avec
impatience de retrouver leur nouvelle
famille l'enfant adopté n'est pas une
page blanche
adopter un enfant c'est aussi adopté sa
vie d'avant pour que ça marche vraiment
il faut que l'enfant soit prêt à être
adoptée et que les parents soient là
aussi sont prêts à adopter un enfant âgé
quoi finalement avec une histoire c'est
moi et moi j'étais près de soissons
j'étais ouais c'est une réussite
en france
plus de 28000 futurs parents attendent
tous ont obtenu l'agrément le permis
d'adopter
comment décide-t-on de leur donner ou
non le droit d'adopter un enfant
c'est au conseil général que leur
histoire commence
c'est ici qu'on délivre l'agrément
certains candidats à l'adoption désir
agrandir leur famille d'autres et c'est
la majorité sont dans l'impossibilité
d'avoir un enfant biologique
après des années d'errance médical pour
vaincre leur stérilité
il se tourne vers l'adoption
des épreuves de la vie auquel s'ajoute
un parcours administratif neuf mois d'
enquêtes médicales sociales
psychologiques afin d'obtenir le fameux
sésame pour adopter
c'est dans cette pièce que se jouent
leur avenir la commission d'agrément
psychologues travailleurs sociaux
juriste représentants d'associations six
personnes sont là pour évaluer la
capacité de ces candidats à assumer
toutes les conséquences d'une adoption
vous en vrai installez vous messieurs
dames
ce couple déjà parent d'enfant
biologique soit adopté trois enfants
[Musique]
alors on a ce sentiment ne pas avoir
toutes les cartes en main parce que
votre projet vous en convenez étape du
projet très spécifiques
1 il ressent pas la majorité des projets
que nous avons à connaître notamment moi
je reviendrai juste sur al points l'âge
l'âge qui est de 5 à 15 ans c'est une
fourchette énorme c'est quand même une
tranche d'âge qui est très particulière
et j'aurais voulu savoir un peu comment
vous est venue cette idée doit adopter
des enfants jusqu'à 15 ans on se dit que
plus on ag - ils vont être adoptés et
que
et que fin ou non pour que ces voix-là
cas pas de ces c'est pas une question
d'âge c'est une question d'enfants c'est
une question là quand même on a 5 15 ans
ce qui implique qu'il ya un enfant qui
va arriver alors qu'il y a une petite
fille qui a fait elle est l'aînée et
d'un second boom son statut elle va le
perdre aussi qu'est-ce qui va se jouer
entre les enfants et ce qui peut sembler
idyllique gentille d'une cohabitation où
tout le monde va s'entraider jouent
ensemble éventuellement quelques
bagarres parce que ça on les imagine
tout de même peut vite se transformer en
foire d'empoigné vient se surajouter
aussi jeu comme ces messieurs dames vous
parler éventuellement d'enfants porteurs
de handicap
donc ça c'est le tien sur le papier ça
démesuré
au départ nous notre projet c'est un si
jamais il y avait un frein même cela
recouvre les regarde je vous invite tous
à aller voir le psychologue vous allez
avancer encore une fois réfléchissez ça
mérite de cheminée voyez
[Musique]
c'est un projet humanitaire dont ils
n'ont pas mesuré les conséquences sur je
suis bien sûr leurs familles selon le
recensement et où ils n'en sont pas
conçues notamment comme aujourd'hui on
sait par expérience que là pour le coup
on est vraiment dans des situations à
haut risque la filiation adoptive n'est
pas comme la filiation biologique ces
deux filiation pour moi qui sont tout à
fait différentes mais qui sont qui ont
leur importance qui ont leurs lettres de
noblesse
aussi bien l'une que l'autre simplement
sont pas ceux d'hier
bah j'adopte mais ça sera comme un
enfant biologique ce sera la même chose
on refera la même chose non ce sont des
enfants qui ont des particularités
différentes
les sourds
vous avez souhaité être là aujourd'hui à
cette commission
est ce que le travail réalisé par les
personnes qui vous ont rencontré
correspond bien aux échanges que vous
avez lu les échanges buysse assez je
dirais bien passé maintenant enfants
dans l'ensemble oui à part je dirais le
temps dans le temps parce que j'ai
trouvé ça très long et franchement pour
enfin pour des futurs parents qui
attendent c'est vrai que c'est très long
voilà alors je vais y aller avec +
caution puisque je vais donc aborder
l'âge
bon vous avez fait le choix donc d'un
projet d'accueil d'un enfant entre 0 et
6 ans bon ça s'avère que c'est possible
pour vous
ça va être plus difficile je pense que
ça va être difficile vu mon adjoint de
moi surtout voilà mais moi je veux tout
faire c'est tout je suppose que bon vous
avez fait ce choix parce que pour vous
vous êtes imaginer maman jusqu'à quel
âge à main d'un enfant et moi si vous
avez passé parce qu'on a eu ce problème
de stérilité autrement moi
personnellement même si j'avais plus
avant un enfant biologique à 46 ans je
l'aurais fait voilà je sens que c'est ça
vous prend un vrai mais c'est normal je
crois qu'on peut pas parler d'un projet
de cet ordre là enfin sans qu'il y ait
des mouvements plus affectif d'émotion
et c'est d'ailleurs important de voir
que vous êtes à deux dans ce projet cher
voilà j'aimerais effectivement
l'adoption il est quand même porté sur 2
2 histoire douloureuse est à l'abandon
d'enfant mais par rapport au couple il y
a quand même le fait qu' il n'y a pas
ils doivent adopter parce qu'ils n'ont
pas pu concevoir ensemble leurs enfants
et portait cette enfant s'il ya vraiment
deux souffrances qu'ils sont
à l'origine de ce parcours et ça n'est
pas facile
pendant ce n'est pas facile c'est la
souffrance evans est le bon allez de
souffrance qui se rencontrent oui
effectivement
enfin moi j'avais envie qu'on s'occupe
de moi
en fait tous rafle j'avais juste envie
qu'on s'occupe de moi qu'on prenne soin
de moi qu'on fasse attention à moi est
en fait le sentiment que j'avais c'est
ce que c'est que c'est un adulte qui
vous demande exactement la même chose
effectivement j'ai réalisé il ya très
peu de temps qu'eux aussi avaient dû ou
auraient dû
on ne sait pas faire le deuil de
l'enfant qui n'avait pas pu avoir et je
ne m'étais jamais imaginé en place de
cet enfant
[Musique]
délivrer un agrément et lourdes
conséquences au conseil général du nord
85% des parents qui le demandent
l'obtiennent dans d'autres départements
c'est 100 % des parents qui ont le
permis d'adopter
[Musique]
l'agrément ce permis leur donne le droit
de devenir parents mais ne garantit en
aucun cas qu'ils trouveront un enfant à
adopter
[Musique]
le docteur soul au chef de service de
pédiatrie à pau est l'un des pionniers
de l'adoption en france il y a vingt ans
ce père adoptif de trois enfants lèvent
le voile sur les difficultés de
l'adoption en créant la première
consultation adoption à l'hôpital depuis
il en existe une quinzaine sur le
territoire ce soir il s'adresse à des
professionnels de l'adoption est un
départ en attente d'enfants le thème de
sa conférence les risques de l'adoption
je suis à la fois heureux d'être parmi
vous ce soir et je suis un peu peiné je
suis même très peiné par ce que il y à
un certain nombre d'entre vous qui vont
partir triste après cette conférence je
m'en excuse
c'est par mon objectif mon objectif est
de vous informer sur l'adoption et comme
je veux être le plus vrai possible
je vais vous dire des choses que
certains d'entre vous vont avoir du mal
entend j'en suis désolé mais j'ai pas
d'autre choix
je serai vrai
l'adoption est là d'abord pour trouver
des parents pour un enfant si bien
entendu ça fait votre bonheur en plus si
absolument indispensable mais on n'est
pas là pour fournir un enfant à les
parents quand on parle d'adoption on est
là pour fournir des parents un enfant
qui n'en a pas parce que c'est un droit
fondamental de l'enfant d'avoir des
parents par contre et j'en suis désolé
il n'y a pas de droit à avoir un enfant
grosso modo et c'est de plus en plus
vrai moins de la moitié des gens qui ont
un agrément seront parents adoptifs
moins de la moitié il ya beaucoup plus
de candidats à l'adoption que d'enfants
adoptables il ya plein d'enfants
malheureux en est d'accord ne sont pas
adoptables
donc nous confondons pas enfin
malheureux et enfin adoptables si on
veut faire que les enfants soient même
moins malheureux dans le monde
bien entendu c'est pas l'adoption qui va
résoudre les problèmes du malheur des
enfants
le couple idéal c'est pour moi qui
l'idéal idéale aux yeux des gens qui
proposent l'enfant c'est le couple homme
femme mariée de moins de 35 ans voilà ça
c'est le couple idéal celui là il est
sûr d'adopter sur 100 % par contre la
femme seule
le couple homosexuel le coût de 50 ans
il a de très fortes chances
de ne pas adopter soyons clairs mais le
risque c'est qu'on va l'en proposé à ces
gens là dans la mesure où on est dans
une pénurie
vous avez bien vu on va leur proposer
soit un enfant dont les jeunes couples
ne veulent pas parce que trop grand
parce que malade où on va leur proposer
un enfant plus jeune dans un pays
monsieur donc ils n'auront que deux
choix soit renoncer au projet soit
adopté dans un pays mafieux il est
scandaleux que en france dans certains
départements on avertit ce pas les gens
de tous ces risques il est scandaleux
qu'on donne l'agrément à tout le monde
il est scandaleux qu'ils aillent pas de
limite d'âge on peut voir 70 ans et
avoir un agrément
je trouve que c'est plutôt mieux que la
dernière fois
parce que
personne encore hurler contre ce que je
disais lanières fois les gens vers l'est
mais ça a peut-être venir
oui mais je suis prêt à assumer
je suis extrêmement confrontés à des
échelles d'adoption et je me dis qu'un
certain nombre de ces échecs aurait
peut-être pu être évité si on avait
plus parler les risques avant l'enfant
rêver ne sera peut-être pas là il ne
sera peut-être pas commis les rêver mais
c'est bien de rêver mais parfois il faut
que les rêves aussi rejoignent la
réalité
après de longues années d'attentes vient
la rencontre avec l'enfant rêvé celui
qui va venir bouleverser leur vie
[Musique]
c'est le choc du face-à-face l'enfant
tente idéalisé devient réel un moment de
vie unique porteurs de sentiments aussi
divers qu'inattendus
y'avait première rencontre déjà c'était
des étrangers pour moi j'ai souvenir de
personnes qui manifestaient de l'émotion
et qui foutait la trouille quoi
[Musique]
j'ai reconnu ma maman ma mère celle qui
allait devenir maman est là d'avoir
finalement tout une attention pour moi
quelqu'un du que je sais qu'ils me mets
qui me voulait et qui le désiraient
basse et s était c'est magnifique on
[Musique]
sait de cet instant là que naissent les
premiers liens de leur histoire d'amour
une grève délicate entre l'enfant
d'ailleurs et son parent qui ne l'a pas
mis au monde chaque année 3000 enfants
viennent de l'étranger pour être adoptés
en france
de plus en plus d'enfants grand et de
fratrie qui débarquent avec leur passé
déracinés de vont devoir s'adapter à une
autre culture
ce n'est plus la même langue la même
nourriture la même couleur de peau
comment les aider à grandir dans cette
nouvelle vie tout en respectant leur
histoire
un défi que leurs parents adoptifs vont
devoir relever
[Musique]
le premier souvenir je me rappelle juste
dans l'avion et j'ai vu un
un lever de soleil addis abeba en
mayenne enfin c'est génial la mayenne
ceni cc je voudrais pas c'est sympa ya
des chevaux y tout fait eh bien on
arrivé là et et ben il faisait beau il y
avait du soleil bas c'était l'été je me
souviens que je chantais des chansons en
corée un camp dans la voiture je je je
manifestais en fait dans une espèce de
d'excitation comme ça de montrer une
certaine joie de vivre enfin des choses
comme ça je parlais souvent de ma vie tu
n'es pas le surtout comme un disque rayé
donc c'était comme si c'était nous qui
sont dus de survie quoi comme si j'avais
peur d'oublier d'où je venais de oui
c'est comme si j'avais peur d'oublier à
mon passé et voilà j'avais une chambre
pour moi tout seul on dit pour moi tout
seul j'avais l'habitude de dormir avec
plein de gens vous pourrez la voir du
tout donc du coup bah ouais c'était un
changement quoi j'ai commencé en fait à
avoir les choses qu'on a à voir que tout
avait changé que que j'étais parti pour
un nouveau départ vas y avait quelque
chose du non-retour points donc il
fallait il fallait que ça fonctionne il
fallait se faire se faire apprécier il
fallait il fallait se faire aimer tout
simplement et et que c'était je pense
qu'inconsciemment il y avait il y avait
quelque chose de l'ordre de l'obligation
qui se faisait en fait de mon côté
en france les difficultés de l'adoption
ne sont plus un tabou pour les
professionnels de l'enfance
il y a vingt ans la première
consultation adoption ouvre à l'hôpital
de pau depuis elle ne désemplit pas la
salle d'attenté du service de pédiatrie
prend des allures de crèches
international colombien brésilien
éthiopien à peine débarqué de l'avion
les parents et leurs enfants viennent
consulter le médecin d adopter telle
évolution
la belle manière dans les bras les coûts
tout petit tueur on regarde tu vois le
teacher accueil téléphone en vingt ans
de pratique
le docteur sous l'eau a beaucoup appris
sur l'adoption il peut déceler des
maladies et certains des traumatismes de
ses enfants qui varie en fonction de
leur pays d'origine
auront-ils bonjour les grandes 6e
journée la main
[Musique]
vous connaissez des choses de leur
histoire que ce qui les a amenés à être
ces décès de leurs parents c'est quoi il
fait du pape à la peña moment qu'il est
gravement malade doit bien c'était à
l'orphelinat depuis longtemps vous savez
notre fille janvier début d'année c'est
tout récent retour et c'est un très bon
d'accord on peut dire tout de suite la
cause essentielle de l'abandon en
ethiopie c'est pas l'abandon si le fait
d'être orphelin c'est à dire que c'est
des enfants dans les parents sont
décédés ou très malade mais ce sont des
enfants certes orphelins certes dans un
milieu très paumés des enfants surtout
qu'ils auraient aimé ces enfants qui ont
été aimé il ça c'est absolument
fondamental c'est absolument fondamental
et moi dans mon expérience les enfants
d'origine éthiopienne vont bien
psychiquement et que ça et bien c'est
des enfants qui s'adapte beaucoup mieux
c'est des enfants qui s'attachent à leur
nouveau par or bon je préfère un petit
commentaire
pour lisa sur son âge dans beaucoup de
pays les pauvres sont encore plus
pauvres parce qu'ils n'ont pas d'état
civil on leur donne pas de date de
naissance et que soit parce que on se
trompe soit parce que on a envie de
favoriser les chances d'adoption d'un
enfant un peu grand il ya une fâcheuse
tendance très répandu en ethiopie de
rajeunir les enfants les plus grands
donc elle n'a pas 7 ans et 5 mois
elle a au moins non plus au moins bon
c'est la cause de l'immense majorité des
soi-disant puberté précoce est ici
adopté est donc l oms
mettons si elle démarre dès sa 9 ans
elle en aura en fait 10 ennemis sera
complètement normal et c'est pas de
puberté précoce à l'âge de 2 de 9 ans
j'ai commencé à avoir des femmes est
effectivement là ça a été très très
douloureux je me sentais vraiment pas
prête d'avoir des seins 9 ans d'être
formés d'avoir mes règles à 10 ans du
coup je me dis que j'essaie de me cacher
c'est ambigu à ce moment là parce qu'en
même temps je voulais me cacher par des
t-shirts et en même temps je voulais me
montrer que j'assume et en fait c'était
pas c'était vraiment très très
ambivalents en fait dans mon
comportement
du coup je me suis sentie différente des
autres et c'est peut-être un peu
ridicule de dire mais du coup je
regardais comme je savais que j'étais
sûrement plus âgés je regardais les
autres personnes de ma classe comme si
c'était des petits début d encre
et
il crie tétanos paul ii est baptisé
nautilus bons qui sont vaccinés comme
sur internet santé français pour moi ce
n'est la colombie c'est pour moi le le
au duo de la qualité et de l'honnêteté
parce que il n'ya pas de transfert
d'argent parce que c'est une action
parfaitement vedette
parce que les dossiers médicaux et
d'aussi sociaux sont parfaitement vrai
parfaitement francs donc ça c'est le
très bon côté mme adoption colombes
vous savez un peu des choses leur
histoire ou de 1 to ils ont des
histoires sont frère et soeur mais ils
ont des histoires très différentes
parce que il en a l as cannes abandonné
même avant la naissance
d'accord à huit mois de grossesse et sa
maman a dit qu'elle voulait abandonner
donc lui par contre avec un an et demi
avec elle donc avec un milieu très basse
elle vient beaucoup d'enfants adoptés en
colombie appartiennent à la catégorie de
ceux que j'appelle ces enfants qui ont
beaucoup souffert
maltraitance aux familles violente
famille compliquée je lui ai dit quelque
chose à un nom et lui j'ai pris cet
aprem cfl et
on fait des appels de ma lui même
je leur ai dit quelque chose on le fait
qu'ils aient vraiment quelque chose sur
laquelle j'assiste et particulièrement
pour les adoptions en colombie c'est sur
l'absence de toute violence dans
l'éducation c'est-à-dire tri faut
essayer de vous abstenir de tout fait
c'est de tout juif de tout prix mais et
on va lui faire on va tout faire
justement pour que la greffe prenne
après la rencontre vient le temps de
tisser les premiers liens au fil des
jours
enfants et parents doivent s'ajuster
s'accorder les uns aux autres un moment
de séduction réciproque un moment où
l'enfant essaie de se fondre dans
l'univers de ces nouveaux parents une
phase décisive dans la filiation
adoptive où chacun cherche sa place
[Musique]
oui l'enfant soit sage heureuse
structuré et structurant enfin j'avais
une vie paisible
j'étais très entourée par la famille par
les amis donc tout se passait bien je
n'avais pas conscience qu'ils avaient y
avait une autre dimension à ma vie
c'était peut-être un déni mais j'ai
aussi fait un jeu pour moi j'étais né
dans le ventre de ma mère et c'est vrai
que pour une enfant de 2 g pas une
enfance et c'est ça me j'ai pensé par
c'était pour moi j'étais comme tout le
monde et voilà bah oui moi je
quand je suis arrivé j'ai vraiment le
souvenir de en tout cas d'essayer de les
aimer quoi il y avait d'essayer de les
aimer comme com com com de nouveaux
parents après ça s'est pas passé comme
ça mais j'ai vraiment le en tout cas
l'intention y était ça c'est sûr mais
c'est vrai que ce côté caméléon sur
adapté d'une certaine manière pour être
sûr de rentrer dans la case est sûr de
ne pas faire de vagues est sûr de pas
être abandonné à nouveau derrière
oui je pense que je correspondais à ce
ce schéma-là fait d'être adoptée à 7 ans
quasiment sept ans ccc pour les parents
qui adoptent
à voir à faire un peu plus a à l'autre
avec son histoire et un pan de sa vie
mais j'irai que cette remarque là en
tout cas pour moi elle vaut aussi elle
vaut tout autant pour pour un enfant
nourrisson parce qu'il aura il aura pas
le les souvenirs du vécu mais j'irai qui
il sera face finalement même question en
grandissant et d'où je viens qui sont
mes parents comment j'en suis arrivée là
l'amour le désir ne suffisent pas
toujours à faire face à l'arrivée d'un
enfant avec son histoire
un constat que fait désormais l'ensemble
du corps médical
depuis une dizaine d'années les
consultations spécialisées dans
l'adoption se multiplient en janvier
2010 à l'hôpital sainte-anne le docteur
pérouse de montclos a créé une
consultation psychologique pour aider
les parents et leurs enfants adoptifs à
s'accorder sa première consultation and
mathy une mère adoptive qu'elle suit
depuis six mois depuis son retour du
mali avec son fils yoann
[Musique]
j'ai vu cette cette dame en boubou
arrivé avec un enfant qu'on bras elle
est arrivée comme ça et s'est approché
de moi et m'a présenté et j'ai vu son
visage était en train de dormir était
magnifique et j'ai même pas pu le
toucher enfin je me suis dit mais
c'était comme un bijou
on est même pas le toucher mais c'est
vrai que quand quand j'ai quand j'ai vu
mon bébé j'ai vu aussi une jeune femme
en fait c'est ça le visage de mon bébé
prend la lisa je m'embrouille avec comme
le visage d'une femme et j'ai toujours
imaginé simplement de l'essence très
très jeunes ou jeunes filles et donc
nous l'impression d'adopter deux dont
deux en corée et donc c'est vrai que
dans ce que je vous dit vous reprenez je
dirais des thématiques qui sont
fréquentes dans votre situation c'est à
dire un petit peu que cet enfant est un
don et que vous sentez quelque part
quelque fois pas an dette vis-à-vis de
la mère de naissance
je pense qu'il me faut encore du temps
pour pour pour me dire que je suis maman
fait maintenant je peux dire c'est mon
but
maintenant je trouve qu'ils là je vois
il me regarde un peu plus on reste
longtemps en train de regarder
et puis je pense que yoann était un
petit peu inquiet et là on a
l'impression qu'il peut enfin commencer
à se poser
ça veut dire qu'il est rassuré il a
compris qu'ils pouvaient vous faire
confiance que vous étiez je dirais la
personne auprès de qui peut se réfugier
quand il ya un souci
et puis regarder tranquillement ce qu'il
vient de faire à l'instant et la regarde
j'adore ça il ya c'est un peu le guignol
parce qu'on est bien
oui vous avez dans l'adoption les mêmes
phénomènes qui se passe pour une mère
biologique qui tout d'un coup au moment
de l'accouchement se trouve face à son
enfant son bébé réel et il ya forcément
je dirais le jeu presque le traumatisme
de l'art et à la confrontation à la
réalité et je crois que la rencontre
entre la mer où les parents et leur
enfant adopté peut être quasiment
presque à la fois une grande joie mais
faire l'effet presque d'un trauma dans
sa soudaineté dans le fait que l'enfant
réel tout d'un coup leur apparaît alors
qu'ils avaient fait tout un travail de
construction d'un enfant imaginaire
[Musique]
au fur et à mesure que l'enfant adopté
grandi il sort de son cocon familial
pour affronter les regards extérieurs à
l'école avec les amis dans la rue des
regards qui l'obligent à prendre
conscience de sa différence
- les choses dont pour lesquelles j'ai
souffert c'est pas dans ma famille c'est
plus dans le regard des autres dans ce
qui m'entoure et
en prime un en cpge était dans une
classe avec une institutrice très
difficile avec un très dur quoi
est-ce comporté avec moi comme avec les
autres enfants donc si je vous allez
même de voir que alors que je comprenais
pas du tout la langue il y à un moment
où le le le fait d'être dans un
environnement on est différent on fait
qu'on vous le renvoi que ce soit au
niveau de la famille que ce soit au
niveau au niveau du jeu séparation va
faire des courses avec sa mère on vous
renvoie vous êtes physiquement différent
et que comment est ce possible que cette
femme blonde aux yeux bleus puis 7 bat
maire enfin ballon
[Musique]
il arrive aussi que le monde extérieur
soit un révélateur des difficultés de
certains de ses enfants
[Musique]
c'est en maternelle que les troubles du
comportement de dimitri y ont été
repérés adopté à l'âge de 3 ans dimitri
a connu l'abandon l'orpheline le
déracinement des ruptures successives
qui ont pour conséquence une peur
panique de s'attacher des problèmes
d'attachement que connaissent beaucoup
d'enfant adopté tardivement
[Musique]
on était chez mes parents pendant
quelques jours
ça s'est bien passé ça s'est mal passé
en même temps il ya eu des moments où
il s'est montré assez agité est toujours
du mal à accepter les règles qu'on
essaye de lui de lui donner
et donc on est toujours dans les mêmes
soucis de crises de colère qui sont
moins fréquentes que par le passé mais
qui existent encore toujours et qui nous
inquiète quelque peu voilà quand votre
enfant réagi comme ça de manière
violente face à une frustration ou fait
une crise pour ce que vous avez ressenti
un sentiment d'impuissance
le fait de ne pas réussir à l'été et
donc avoir un sentiment de culpabilité
de se dire on n'est pas le bon parent ce
qu'on n'avait pas du tout compris au
départ que c'était de la souffrance de
la part de cet enfant qu'il exprimait à
travers l'agressivité et ils nous aiment
on n'a aucun doute sur son sur son amour
on parle d'adoption comme le parcours du
combattant pour les papiers pour
l'administratif mais on ne pense pas à
la poste
adoption c'est vrai qu'on idéalise
l'enfant qui arrive parce qu'on l'a
tellement attendu
on l'a tellement souhaité que c'est une
idéalisation total et l'enfant qui
arrive n'est pas du tout l'enfant
idéalisée et rêver ses enfants des
comportements quelquefois de rejet
d'abord ces enfants n'ont pas connu une
attention affective aussi soutenue que
celle qu'ils ont avec leurs parents
adoptifs et ils vivent cette attention
extrême d'un parent ans adoptants qui a
été très en attente pendant des années
de cet enfant comme quelque chose de
dangereux quoi d'inhabituel et d'intrus
cif alors que sont des enfants qui est
obligé de se débrouiller tout seul il
n'est pas facile d'adopter un enfant
avec son histoire
comme il n'est pas toujours facile
d'adopter ces nouveaux parents
pour david il a fallu du temps pour que
la greffe prenne de sata à 11 ans j'ai
vécu pleinement avec eux et c'était
c'était difficile et ces quatre années
là je crois que entre ma mère attendait
un fils aimant et je crois que je je je
crois que je lui donnait pas
satisfaction à ce niveau là et que en
retour le elle me faisait un peu payé le
fait d'être nature une certaine réserve
où est donc je suis allé dans un
internat spécialisés quand j'avais 11
ans ce qui était important c'est que
j'ai un nouvel environnement dans lequel
je puisse gérer un peu plus exister et
je l' ai vécu plus comme commun comme
une délivrance presque
david va vivre toute son adolescence en
pension loin de ses parents adoptifs
bah
les années passent et vient
l'adolescence le corps change et les
questions se font de plus en plus
pressante
l'adolescent adopté tenté par la
blessure de son abandon qui ressurgit
brutalement
c'est la fin du mirage
il réalise que ses parents adoptifs ne
seront jamais ses parents biologiques
quand je suis rentré à l'adolescence je
commençais vraiment à me poser des
questions et je me disais vu que je
grossis c'est un peu je me disais est ce
que c'est génétique
est ce que ma mère elle est même
rondeurs que moi enfin c'est vrai que
j'essaye vraiment de trouver des
réponses mais bon je pouvais pas
tellement en avoir je me suis rendu
compte plus tard que c'était très
difficile d'avoir grandi sans un miroir
génétique à plus forte raison en étant
blanche puisque je me suis donné
l'illusion d'être française c'est très
difficile parce que comme j'ai vu un
témoignage quelque part un jour la
personne disait oui vous êtes mes
parents ils nous n'avons pas les mêmes
ancêtres et j'ai trouvé ça très beau
parce que c'est vraiment ça on n'a pas
les mêmes ancêtres et mon visage et mon
être crie hurle vraiment l'appartenance
à une autre lignée génétique
je pense que jose que si j'ai fait une
grosse crise d'adolescence
c'est un ensemble de tous donc il y
avait mon passé qu'a été douloureux le
fait d'avoir été maltraité le fait d'un
d'avoir changé de pays
le fait de
de rentrer à l'école et du coup je
compose sans arrêt la même question
parce que mes parents ne me ressemblait
pas j'ai complètement perdu mes repères
je savais plus où j'en étais je savais
plus ce que je voulais et j'ai pour moi
dans ce dans ce cas là c'était quand je
me disais je me laissais aller c'est que
malheureusement j'avais l'intention de
de partir d'une peut être sur terre
[Musique]
le schip service de pédopsychiatrie
dans ce service douze jeunes qui
souffrent de pathologies aiguës psychose
dépression troubles du comportement
souvent violents ils sont hospitalisés
pour se protéger d'eux-mêmes et protéger
leur entourage sur 12 patients
il y a toujours au moins un enfant
adopté
tous ces adolescents qui arrivent
parfois en urgence 4 à 10% sont des
jeunes qui ont été adoptées ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'ils sont sur
représentés par rapport à leur classe
d'âge et que quand on a été adopté il ya
[Musique]
un risque d'avoir des difficultés
psychiques qui justifie une
hospitalisation
entre dix et vingt fois plus
que pourra un adolescent tout venant
[Musique]
clara est bon élève jusqu'en classe de
sixième jusqu'au décès de son père
adoptif un choc brutal qui la plonge
dans la dépression depuis un an et demi
elle est hospitalisée en psychiatrie
sous traitement des fois tu pas bien
pour faire passer mme a des jambes je
passe moi sommes beaucoup plus je suis
dit au dessus du suicide seule issue
quand je suis ici depuis je suis ici je
ne fais deux quand je les ai depuis 10
mois je fais ici normanville ma chemise
je pensais pas je me sens différente pas
comme les autres quand je suis bon je
suis bien je sais pas quand effet que
même ça fait bizarre de surf est adopté
quand j'ai su ça m'a fait bizarre
en tout cas moi si j'avais un enfant je
laisserai pas tomber quoi
après ce que j'ai vécu clara fait partie
de ces orphelins roumains que le monde a
découvert dans les années 90 cent mille
enfants livrés à eux mêmes dans les
institutions d'état
difficile de croire au paradis familiale
lorsqu'on a été nourri pendant des mois
à travers les barreaux d'un lit cage
obligé de se balancer pour se sentir
exister les 15 premiers mois de la vie
de clara
un passé douloureux qu'elle aborde pour
la première fois avec son psychiatre et
sa mère adoptive
bon on fait le point par rapport à
comment tu vas aujourd'hui tu te sens
bien aujourd'hui mieux qu'hier
hier tu étais pas beaucoup dormi un pit
avait un peu mal partout
comme souvent mal partout comme souvent
jeudi à ce qu'on se disait il n'ya pas
très longtemps c'est que tu tu exprimes
beaucoup tes difficulté à travers ton
corps elle passe tout de suite dans le
corps forcément
est-ce que des fois quand tu te sens
très mal tu as des images de cette
première période de ta vie qui te
revienne ou des sensations a
l'impression me dit fois j'ai des fois
j'ai pas j'ai pas boudé choix sur
renault était là-bas chose alors juste
c'était un hôpital ou un orphelinat g20
pour moi c'est un c'était c'était un
hôpital c'était un hôpital mais
orphelinat il y avait que des enfants
abandonnés dans cet hôpital et ça allait
du bébé aux enfants de 5 6 ans donc elle
était beaucoup laissé à lui même d'après
ce que vous savez tout ce qu'il y avait
aucun amour il y avait aucun aucun corps
à corps toute façon ça c'est sûr donc
les enfants étaient dans leur lit et il
n'y avait rien quoi il y avait ma
couverture système atlas qui est super
chaud fait en pyjama et c'est tout quoi
y avait des jouets dans une seule mais
les enfants jouaient pas avec en fait
donc il n'y avait rien personne n'a lu
parlé tout semble donc quand vous avez
fait connaissance donc toi tu avais 17
mois c'est ça et
j'ai pas quelles étaient vos premières
impressions quand vous avez fait
connaissance elle ne tendaient pas les
bras elle ne souriait pas elle et elle a
regardé un passé quoi je veux dire et
elle tu étais son brad est resté
longtemps à téter tombera parce que tu
n'avais rien d'autre pour mais pour toi
je me demande si de cette période là tu
ne garde pas un besoin très fort de
sentir ton corps plus que toute autre
chose et que du coup c'est compliqué
pour toi de d'exprimer autrement qu'à
travers ton corps c'est à dire c'est tu
reviens à ton corps dès que tu te sens
mal parce que c'est comme ça que tu as
survécu au tout début parce qu'on peut
imaginer que dans les conditions
décrites par ta maman pour survivre tu
devais te concentrer sur tes sensations
corporelles et surtout pas essayer
d'avoir des émotions ou des choses comme
ça en tant que parent adoptif
c'est sûr qu'il ya plein de choses dont
on est parent n'a pas conscience on sait
mais on n'a pas pleinement conscience et
et moi maintenant quand je revois fanton
l'a adopté elle est devenue notre fille
mais à part entière c'est comme si je
l'avais fait moi même je veux dire ben
pour moi je la portais le bonheur à ma
fille enfin l'amour le bonheur quoi
et qu'elle ne pouvait qu'être heureuse
donc quelque part tout en sachant son
passé gelé quand même oublié et là c'est
vrai que pour les parents qui adoptent
ça c'est une chose quand même pas
oublier quand on reprend l'histoire des
enfants qui arrivent ici les difficultés
sont anciennes
pré existe déjà depuis plusieurs années
mais justement les professionnels et
parfois des familles mettent ça sur le
compte de l'adoption du temps qu'il faut
pour que les choses s'installent de
manière sereine et serra et c'est
négliger toutes les facteurs de
fragilité qui sont liées à l'abandon
lui même s'est plus l'abandon qui fait
le nid de certaines difficultés que
l'adoption g la part de trabant donné ça
arrive que lorsque enfin certaines
relations affectif avec mes copines
c'est c'est que dans ces moments là où
où je sens que je perds pied en fait
c'est vrai que je doute toujours de
demain capacité à être aimé de quelqu'un
ou apprécier comme c'est dans le cadre
même de faim d'amitié ou de laisser
quelque chose qui est qui m'angoisse
quand même savoir est ce que est ce
qu'on va m'aimer mais est-ce que si on
aime
est-ce que ça va durer dans le temps dès
qu'on sent qu'il ya un signe qu'on peut
être quitter ou que l'amitié peut
prendre d'autres formes on préfère
partir avant parce que c'est trop
difficile à gérer de revivre un abandon
et ça ça tous les âges et à tous les
âges et les adosser les jeunes adultes
chez les adultes et les personnes plus
âgées parce qu'on reste un enfant adopté
ou plus précisément un enfant abandonné
honnêtement mes parents ils ont pas
toujours que tout compris parce que
j'étais tellement perdus dans ce que je
voulais dans ce que lorsque j'étais dans
la souffrance tant dans la colère
il aurait très bien pu - en fait oui me
laisser tomber en fait même abandonné
une seconde fois
enfin une première fois pour eux et une
seconde fois pour moi en fait ils n'ont
pas fait donc c'est comme un mariage et
mon prix pour le meilleur et pour le
pire parfois la greffe ne prend pas
troubles de l'attachement chez l'enfant
rejet du parent l'adoption tourner à
l'échec
il y à 11 ans florence et son mari déjà
parents de trois enfants biologiques
adopte un enfant grands ils
l'abandonnent
cinq ans plus tard un lourd secret pour
cette famille qui a décidé de sortir du
silence
une adoption c'est définitif on ne
revient pas dessus
normalement
jusqu'au jour où ça devient complètement
insupportable et là qu'est ce qu'on fait
en ce ce flingue on fait quoi pour que
ça s'arrête pour que ce soit supportable
pour que la vie redevient nuit
il
jonathan est né en france il a un an
quand sa mère biologique est emporté par
la maladie confié à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance
il passe six années dans une famille
d'accueil son père lui rend visite de
temps en temps puis de moins en moins
jusqu'au jour où il ne vient plus il
signe un acte d'abandon qui rend
l'adoption de jonathan possible à l'âge
de 7 ans jonathan rencontre pour la
première fois ces nouveaux parents
[Musique]
c'était très émouvant parce que c'était
le jour où où nous avions un enfant de
plus et avec la particularité de le
vivre avec nos autres enfants toute la
famille y arriver là nous pour découvrir
notre nouvelle enfants et les autres
pour nos trois enfants pour découvrir
leurs frères
mo
moi je parlais pas trop puisque est un
peu impressionnés normal mais il me
parlait tous - tranquillement mais et
j'avais dame en tout cas découvrir que
voilà quoi jr je vais regarder un peu
les lieux le temps de connaître un peu
mes frères et soeurs vient de redire
leur prénom de retenir j'ai ainsi aussi
eux qui m'ont mis au vert entre
guillemets à l'aise pour que je puisse
rentrer quand même dans leur famille
tout doucement son manque plus que ça me
manque plus que ça me bloque négrier il
sautait il jouait aux sables avec ses
frères et soeurs des petits signes comme
ça au départ nous y sommes accrochés en
se disant c'est bon il prend racine est
vrai que le tableau aurait été pris avec
une photo à l'instant t
ça aurait fait un tableau idéal et
peut-être que c'était trop idéal
un an plus tard la lune de miel des
début cèdent la place aux
incompréhensions
jonathan s'isole ses parents se braquent
le lien se fragilise
je n'arrivais pas à le saisir
comme une image qui bouge tout le temps
et on voudrait capter des traits comment
il est vraiment et aujourd'hui je crois
que je sais toujours pas je le revois
par exemple là où et à sa table dans sa
chambre où je disais je te demande
d'apprendre de faire ça c'est important
et puis tu sais le faire donc je vois
pas pourquoi tu ne pourrais pas le faire
il bloquait demander beaucoup trop de
mes capacités où il ira j'avais 7 ans et
pas lire ni écrire
je veux dire à brahim boufous les deux
skoda voulait il voulait beaucoup trop
quoi c'était au quotidien et une
succession de petites choses fatigante
énervante usante qui rendait la vie
difficile et qui ne favorisait pas le
lien du coup quoi ok on se met à table
tu viens au nom je veux jouer
non j'ai un parent non mais ça va pas si
si chacun en fait qu'à sa tête ça peut
pas coller tu reviens de l'école ton
blues ont battu les spas parterre tulle
accroche on en porte manteau j'avais pas
l'impression de lui demander la lune et
c'est comme si lui demander la lune
j'acceptais pas vraiment ma vie enfin la
vie que j'avais vécu avant enfin le gère
pour eux c'était de suite fait les
choses comme il fallait que je sois allé
ailleurs comme en avant qui n'ait comme
je veux dire il n'a pas eu la peau
divergent donc là c'est un flic pas moi
de mon côté ça va bloquer et plus de
leur côté après je pense que tout haut
de l'énervement que me bloque et une
tension que s'est créé que je serai un
jour il a essayé de fumier est parti
j'en ai marre je m'en vais tout je les
rattraper et je me souviens
avoir quasiment pleurer devant lui en
lui disant mais pourquoi est ce que tu
vas pas que je t'aime et ce jour là
c'était toujours mon fils il s'était mis
en tête comme que je voulais pas de leur
amour j'adore s'était focalisée sur un
truc qui était pour moi complètement fou
malade et usant de penser et de
réfléchir j'ai besoin de me poser et je
crois que c'est peut-être à partir de là
que ça ça commençait à quelques que la
greffe n'a pas pu se faire parce que
nous nos valeurs familiales par rapport
aux valeurs de jonathan
nous n'étions pas même au même niveau je
crois donc j'ai sûrement dû mettre trop
de pression mais sur le coup je ne
voyais pas je ne n'avais pas le
sentiment de mettre trop de pression et
des trop exigeant au bout de quatre
années d'adoption et après une thérapie
familiale vivre ensemble devient
impossible
florence et françois confie
provisoirement jonathan à l'aide sociale
à l'enfance
c'était invivable pour tout le monde
nos autres enfants reprenaient leur
marque aussi et puis voilà c'était un
balancement absence la semaine le
week-end avec vous un autre rythme et
puis c'est devenu pire de provisoire la
séparation devient définitive après cinq
années d'adoption il abandonne
officiellement jonathan concrètement
nous l'avons abandonné
concrètement nous avons signé les mêmes
papiers que signaux une maman la
maternité quand elle ne peut pas garder
son enfant c'est le même papier que nous
allons signer sauf que lui il avait 13
ans je pense que jonathan n'était pas
adoptables dans le cadre que nous lui
proposions
que nous étions trop trop différents par
contre la petite structure familiale
mais sans investissement affectif était
vraiment ce qui était bon pour lui
est-ce que ça ça aurait pu être décelé
dès le début c'est pas moi qu'il faut
poser cette question là à l'âge de 13
ans jonathan est abandonnée une seconde
fois de nouveaux pupille de l'état
il quitte le foyer pour un lieu de vie
de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
claude et pascal un couple d'anciens
instituteurs spécialisés accompagne
jonathan depuis son abandon et l année
où tu arrivé à 19 ans se fait 5 quand ça
va faire cinq ans là on était un petit
garçon tout timide
ce mobile avec ton petit hamster
soulager peut-être d'arriver dans un
nouveau lieu d'être un autre résultat
où est ce que je vais quand même écoulé
mais c'est pas vrai semaine dernière non
mais à part ça après tu t'es drôlement
bien habitués sont assez vite comme un
secteur ouest puis c'est vrai qu'on
n'avait pas beaucoup d'exigences par
rapport à l'école ça ne changeait de ta
famille adoptive
j'ai maintenant on a eu beaucoup de mal
à le faire partir
les jeunes qu'on a ici on a eu plusieurs
jeunes qui étaient en rupture d'adoption
il avait besoin de faire une coupure est
ce que ça c'était trop dix ans pour les
parents je crois que les parents
adoptifs ne sont pas non plus à
suffisamment aidé un moment donné il
sous prétexte de bien faire il les
aggrave la situation et lisa le
détériore la relation le problème de
l'adoption c'est que très souvent on
essaye de se blesse en tant que deux
projetés sur le gamin ce que l'on
aimerait qu'il soit et c'est pour ça que
ça marche pas combien d'enfants comme
jonathan peuvent se remettre du
traumatisme d'un deuxième abandon en
france 10% des enfants adoptés serait
rendu à l'aide sociale à l'enfance ou
renvoyés dans leur pays d'origine
les échecs de l'adoption un secret bien
gardé
[Musique]
au fur et à mesure que l'enfant adopté
construit sa relation avec ses parents
qu'elle soit sereine non conflictuelle
une question ne cesse de le hanter
d'où je viens arrivé à l'âge adulte
certains décident de reconstituer le
puzzle de leur histoire pour continuer à
vivre pour être en paix avec leur
adoption
il part à la recherche de leurs origines
j'ai commencé à me poser la question et
donc du coup a essayé à faire des
démarches dans ce sens là quand j'avais
j'avais plus de trente ans donc je les
fais en fait assez sur le tard en mai
parce que les années d'avant je les ai
pas c'est plus ça ait trempé avec avec
moi et puis avec dans la relation les
parents en fait adoptif et donc in fine
est resté restait toujours la question
de la de l'abandon de du besoin de danse
avoir quelque chose en étant devenus
adultes de d'en savoir un peu plus sur
sur les premières années de ma vie
on a envie de savoir quand même dont
bien on a envie de le connaître
où sont nos origines ou ce qu'on vivait
comment on vivait même si on les connaît
finalement mais bon ma part c'était plus
une confirmation de ce que j'avais
c'était un peu austère manque
il a vraiment fallu je monte dans
l'avion pour le kosovo pour me rendre
compte que j'étais un pays accessible
sur la même planète dans le même
continent en plus parce que j'avais
vraiment toujours imaginé ça comme un
endroit imaginaire rêver qui
n'existaient pas j'avais pas d'ancrage
la demande et c'est très impressionnant
parce que c'est pas direct mais bon on
peut y attendent une demi journée quand
même et ça n'existait pas j'étais très
excité je pense d'y aller 2
d'aller en cours et
c'était quelque chose que je m'étais
plus ou moins imaginer faire un jour
dans ça me paraissait surréaliste coincé
beaucoup d'appréhension comment ça va
être comment je vais vivre les choses
[Musique]
malgré ses appréhensions maylis est
parti en quête de ses origines
adoptée avec son frère biologique thomas
ils ont quitté la corée quand elle avait
un an et lui quatre ans et demi
[Musique]
chacun regarde
on s'est pour une fois autres avec des
gens mais comme non physiquement
fondus dans la masse mais même si
finalement il me ressemble je me suis je
me suis sentie étrangère quoi en fait on
a deux vies dans une quoi en fait comme
ça quoi enfin moi c'est comme ça que je
vais je vis les choses
j'ai l'impression d'avoir eu deux vies
donc il ya eu ma vie en corée puis ma
vie en france et en grandissant et en
vieillissant il ya le
la vie d'avant qui acquit à laquelle je
dois je faire une place en fait dans
cette quête l'enfant adopté est partagé
entre deux histoires de filiation
comment rester fidèle à ses parents
adoptifs tout en recherchant ses parents
biologiques
un conflit de loyauté que maylis n'a pas
eu à vivre ses parents jean luc et
françoise se prépare à ce voyage depuis
le premier jour de l'adoption
sont des enfants adoptés c'était une
évidence pour ancrer cette recherche qui
aurait
un moment donné des question qui se
poserait sur leur identité et donc au
pont ça faisait partie entre guillemets
du contrat moral que de les aider à
devenir adulte et devenir adulte c'est
aussi se connaître et
on a enfin je pense qu'on souvient jean
luc moudenc aucune inquiétude sur le
fait qu'il retrouve ses parents
biologiques de ce qui va se passer
quand même une coupure de 25 ans dont il
n'y a pas forcément des liens qui ce
regret après mais au moins une voix à
qui ressemble au père à la mère aussi
avec des frères des soeurs
voilà les grands pas
accompagner ses enfants dans la quête de
leurs origines peut être douloureux pour
les parents certains se sentent rejetés
mise à l'écart par ces enfants qui n'ont
pas conçu toute ma famille a eu peur que
je m'en aille vivre avec les parents que
j'avais retrouvé
j'ai pas compris je suis pas partir que
ce nouveau rejeté mes parents je suis
parti me trouvais moi ça les concerne
même pas à la limite non pas se sentir
attaqué ou remis en cause puisque c'est
moi que ça concerne c'est moi qui sais
pas dans quelle terre sont mes pieds est
sûr qu'elle soit je peux marcher ce
qu'il faut bien là quelque part le
nombre d'ados tkip l'année qui savent
pas quoi faire leur vie et qui saborde
tout le temps moi la première
un moment ça fait du bien de sentir d'où
on vient
ellis est thomas ont décidé de remonter
le fil de leur histoire avec racines
coréennes une association d'enfants
adoptés aujourd'hui ils vont à
l'orphelinat où ils ont été abandonnés
23 ans plutôt qu'à ce moment là je me
sens tendu
j'appréhende est-ce que je vais avoir ce
que je veux ou pas et en même temps
qu'est ce que je veux exactement je sais
pas facile mais je sais qu'il va se
passer quelque chose d'important que
c'est un peu à mon bon
mots clés on va dire j'ai l'impression
de
manquer de souffle
[Musique]
est-ce que je vais avoir des infos pour
retrouver la trace de mes parents tout
ça puis revenir à l'endroit où
nous on a été vingt ans auparavant placé
[Musique]
voilà ce moment j'ai peur de savoir
comment je vais réagir
est-ce que je vais être submergé par les
émotions
et en même temps c'est clairement ce que
je vois ce que je veux faire et ce que
j'attends le holt le plus grand centre
d'adoption de la corée du sud comme
miley c'est thomas 76 mille enfants
transité par cet orphelinat pour être
adoptés à l'étranger
[Musique]
rhenatic à regarder
j'avais un angle dont j'ai à peu près le
même âge que moi je me dis que
qui va qui va sur un peu le même
parcours que moi
finalement peut-être après
[Musique]
je suis pas su comprendre ce qui leur
arrive moi j'ai eu l'opportunité d'aller
voir au kosovo où je suis né exactement
et je suis retournée et retourner est
retournée et un jour j'en avais plus
faisant je savais où c'était chaud je
suis né là non je profite je bouge je
vous sais quelle importance
maintenant ça n'a plus d'importance
revenir serait traces de leur passé ne
suffit pas toujours rose adopter
certains ressentent le besoin d'aller
plus loin et cherche à comprendre le
pourquoi de leur abandon voilà vous êtes
prêts ouais ok donc ça c'est votre
dossier
alors ça c'est la page on fait c'est le
bun 26 confidentielles
il confie dans celle de votre famille en
fait ça s'est pas très bien passé le
père buvait beaucoup et bien je de
l'argent
comme ça et ça a causé pas mal de
problèmes en fait dans le couple on va
dire à cause de ça et au moment où ça
allait vraiment pas bien pour les
finances a eu ta soeur et à la naissance
ils ont divorcé et comme elle pouvait
pas subvenir aux besoins elle a décidé
de vous au préalable
donc comme vous pouvez le savoir
il est retrouvé les traces de votre père
et de votre mère biologique
voilà après si vous avez une seule
hésitation
saviez vous n'êtes pas prêt parce que
vouloir les rechercher dire qu'on les a
trouvés ils aient rencontré c'est
complètement différent donc maintenant
ce que je veux savoir c'est vraiment
qu'est ce que vous voulez vraiment vous
voilà je pense qu'on a besoin d'un
panama nous envie
voir et war 3
non je me sens pas prêt donc j'ai pris
la décision de pas y chercher enfin mon
dossier de l'ouvrir et de savoir la
vérité parce que d'un côté je me dis
cette femme qui était ma mère n'a pas pu
me garder
elle avait forcément des raisons et je
me dis que si je feins j'aimerais pas
qu'elle vienne dans ma vie et qu'elle me
dise je suis ta mère biologique et je me
dis je me vois mal
arrivé dans la sienne et dire je suis ta
fille est ce que tu te souviens de moi
tu m'a abandonné vient le jour de la
rencontre
une rencontre que d'omar doute que
maylis idéalise une rencontre à huis
clos avec leur mère biologique qui l'ont
souhaité garder pour eux
par moments je la vois je suis un peu
surprise déjà et je le reconnais pas
bizarre de dire ça mais là je trouve pas
que je lui ressemble je ne trouve pas
spécialement belle
je pense que vraiment avant de connaître
enfin on idéalise beaucoup moi j'ai
beaucoup idéalisée et la rencontre et la
personne
après leur mère biologique ce sont leurs
grands parents maternels qui veulent
revoir meili c'est thomas des petits
enfants qui n'ont pas vu grandir
[Musique]
ces toitures gré
j'anime a grandi tu es tellement joli et
ses toits du mois
[Musique]
merci d'être là et de les avoir fait
grandir
de les voir ému aussi ça m'émeut mais ce
sont des étrangers
quand ils me prennent dans leurs bras ça
me l'émotion que j'ai c'est juste le
fait de des retrouvailles et de mai mais
j'ai pas d'attachement
j'ai pas de jeu pas être attachés à
quelqu'un que je connais pas quand elle
était petite elle était tout le temps à
6 comme ça son visage était toute en
longueur mais maintenant tu es tellement
jolie
parce que ce que nous ressentons déjà
parce que trop sur les photos d'elle
bébé elle me ressemblait un peu mais en
grandissant sonné et plus jolie a trouvé
que j'avais comme ça non
je peux vous raconter les choses que je
faisais quand j'étais petit
il était vraiment très intelligente et
quand je l'emmenais avec moi il était
toujours très bien élevés une saluer
tout le monde
tout le monde le trouvait très
intelligent et encore aujourd'hui
beaucoup de gens se souviennent de lui
et des lui que ses lèvres ressemble à
celle de sa mère et moi j'en ai marre de
ressemble à personne
j'ai du mal à me sentir appartenir à
quelque chose
ils ont beaucoup plus de choses à dire
sur sur thomas mais oui mais je sais et
épurée il a les mêmes lèvres il
ressemble à londres moi je ressemble
j'appartiens à rien
moi je vais te dire je suis content que
cette rencontre ait eu lieu et c'est
surtout très contente que votre grand
mère ta mère elle montre pas à pas grand
chose effectivement mais ta grand mère
elle montre que vous avez compté et que
vous lui avait manqué donc c'est plus
sur notre grand mère te contentes que
nous aurons louis basque parce que je
suis sûre aujourd'hui qui a eu de
l'affection pour vous et donc que tu as
eu ton importance mais de notre mère je
crois pas ah non elle ne montre pas
mentir mais elles ne montrent pas là
n'est que peut être elle est plus
pudique
voilà et puis peut-être qu'elle a plus
de culpabilité aux citoyens comme c'est
la mer que bon et que tu as moins de
points de repères que ton frère tu as
moins de réponses mais c'est la moins
d'importance non t'as pas moins
d'importance n'y a pas moins important
allez
j'avais de l'importance
[Musique]
la joie
ben
ah ouais
ready lorsque tu mets mais bon moi je
veux bien leur dire mais comme tu m'as
dit alors que tu t'es pas sûr qu'ils
comprennent tu vois moi j'en ai souffert
par exemple via des conséquences quand
même tu vois moi je me sens je me suis
sentie abandonnée par importante et
voilà
car il donne à jean blanc que l'union de
william interview de sarah moon palace
au casino
ça met mal à l'aise non
ce qui me regarde mais sont mal à l'aise
non de savoir ça tu leur as dit ce que
ce que je ressentais mais je pense que
ça les met mal à l'aise qua non
bon bon courage dans leur langue pour ta
recherche de travail
mon travail c'est avec ces terrains et
que toi tu feras c'est ce que tu as
envie de faire que si tu avais
madelin quoi
[Musique]
des vélos ça dure un autre incompris
soins entre l'imaginaire et la réalité
des fois il ya un fossé quoi mais je
reviens je regrette pas du tout d'y être
allé j'ai pu m'identifier physiquement
moi c'est quand même quelque chose qui
est important la famille biologique
bella était présente elle a été absente
elle est de nouveau présente et il faut
lui trouver une place
avec aussi toutes les attentes des
parents biologiques qui qui retrouvent
leurs enfants c'était pour eux c'est
dans la continuité aussi j'ai envie
alors manifestez l'émotion est là on se
retrouve de nouveau à elle était obligée
de de trouver une place dorée amorcé un
lien ou de réinventer un lien avec
[Musique]
on n'est pas reconnaissant envers ses
parents j'ai pas je pense pas je pense
pas qu'un enfant biologique dirais je
suis reconnaissant envers entendre ouais
ouais je me considère un peu comme leurs
enfants biologiques et je me considère
comme leur enfant enfin à part entière
et mais j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
eux pour ce qu'ils ont fait pour la
façon dont ils te fais avec l'art et la
manière
ils ont tout fait pour que pour jeux
soient épanouis
aujourd'hui je suis pas remise mais mais
je me régénère et je vais mieux de mieux
en mieux je dirais
ouais quand on se nourrit on se
construit grâce à son parcours le
parcours sera très beau
[Musique]